gushing about iconic on-screen moments
is the ultimate pastime
let's be real but have you ever stopped
to consider how awkward bringing those
romances to life could be for the actors
especially actors who have history with
one another today we're going over
celebs like lily reinhardt and cole
sprouse who had to continue their
on-screen romance
after calling it quits in real life
awkward
lily reinhardt and cole sprouse
riverdale's lovebirds
that brought us adorable content both on
screen and in real life
until they broke up and tore our hearts
in two but that wasn't the worst part
despite calling it quits they both had
to return to set and film riverdale
season 4 and season 5
where their character's love life was
still very much active
imagine your job was having to kiss and
flirt with your ex
all day luckily for them their
relationships seem to have ended on a
friendly note
cole even wrote her one last love note
on his instagram
what an incredible experience i had i'll
always feel lucky and cherished that i
had the chance to fall in love
i wish her nothing but the utmost love
and happiness moving forward
their relationship might have ended in
real life but at least we still have
bughead
are we right please don't make me sing
the kissing booth hooked us right from
the opening scene
and the chemistry between joey king and
jacob alordy just sealed the deal on our
obsession
the heavy chemistry between these two
actors became a reality off-screen as
well
they dated throughout the filming of the
first film but before they could get
back on set for the sequel
joey and jacob were no more but they
still brought the same chemistry for the
kissing booth 2 and the kissing booth 3.
joey even admitted it was worth making
the sacrifice of filming with him again
to bring the film to life
i hope that this opportunity that i'm
getting is not hurting their feelings
although it might be hard the two have
both moved on to new relationships
jacob is now with zendaya and joey is
with stephen piatt
yup penny and leonard were the real deal
behind the scenes of their hit comedy
series
at least for a small amount of time the
co-stars started dating in 2007 when the
show first began airing and then ended
things in 2009.
johnny's actually one of my best friends
it's a situation that ended well
they had to continue to act as if they
were in love all the way until 2020.
it's a good thing their relationship
didn't end with a big bang
or their on-screen story might have
looked a lot different even kaylee is
grateful for how it went down
take a listen and he's one of my dearest
friends and
ryan loves him johnny liz it's been a
long time so we're it's great
i got lucky they say history repeats
itself and olivia rodrigo and joshua
bassett are proving just how true that
is
remember the vanessa hudgens and zac
efron drama
well high school musical the musical the
series has drama of its own
olivia and joshua reportedly had some
romance off screen with one another
but olivia released an original song
driver's license
telling everyone all the heartbreak the
relationship caused her
part of the reason for their breakup
apparently had to do with sabrina
carpenter
i love you
season one of the show might have
wrapped but season two is just around
the corner
and their characters are very much in
love
kelly and ryan weren't jim and pam but
their chemistry was through the roof
probably because they had their own on
and off relationship behind the scenes
a relationship they admit was based on
their own off-screen romance
their workplace romance lasted
throughout a lot of the series but
faded towards the later seasons that
means even though they cooled things off
they had to finish kelly and ryan's
romance while broken up
luckily the two are still the best of
friends and don't plan on changing that
anytime
soon amanda seyfried and dominic cooper
had us falling in love with them on and
off screen
but a few years after mamma mia was
released they really said
don't go wasting your emotions they
ended their two-year relationship in
2011
but then went on to reprise their roles
as husband and wife for mamma mia here
we go again
these two weren't so lucky when it came
to their friendship afterwards
it was nothing more than professional
and maybe to amanda
a little strange honestly you couldn't
tell on camera so
it's a win for them we were friends
longer than we even dated like we've
been friends for
seven years jennifer lawrence got her
happy ending with her husband cook
maroney
but before that she found herself stuck
in some awkward sauce
she dated her x-men co-star nicholas for
four years before they decided to cool
things down
little did they know they'd have to see
each other on set for
two more x-men films where their
characters were still
a thing what do you think
i think you're beautiful but thanks to
her bluntness
j-law says she avoided any true bad
blood between them
k-stew and r-pats were the true
heartthrobs of the millennial generation
and we're still not over them not being
end game at least
off screen even if you were team jacob
you knew robsten was the real deal
sadly after a cheating scandal and a
heartbreaking apology from kristen
this momentary indiscretion has
jeopardized the most important thing in
my life the person i love and respect
the most
rob i love him i love him i'm so sorry
their love story came to an end except
they still had to finish filming
breaking dawn part 2
where they were playing soul mates
lovely
you may have wanted teen wolves alison
and scott to end up together but you
can't deny the chemistry between her
and isaac especially because they were
together outside of work
the awkward thing is their characters
got together on the show
after they had already broken up in
2013.
crystal was so heartbroken she took a
trip to paris to heal
and to jump start her singleness these
one tree hill stars dated
got married and got a divorce all while
being lovers on screen
that must have been a huge emotional
rollercoaster
on top of all of that chad and sophia
had to deal with show producers and
other cast and crew talking about their
personal lives
and even using it as an influence for
the show's storylines
are we the only ones that think that's
wrong in every way
chad wasn't the only one sophia had a
romance with off-screen
she also dated austin nichols towards
the end of the series
and ended up having to film the final
season while their characters were still
together
this breakup was much more civil than
the last he just
wasn't the one for her these two actors
hit it off
right away and dated from when the oc
started filming
all the way to 2006 but that meant in
the final season of the show
their characters were together but they
weren't
years later rachel is apologizing to all
the fans hearts she's broken but wanted
to make sure people knew her and adam
always stayed close
even after the breakup sometimes happy
endings aren't what we expect
before penn was the notorious netflix
stalker he was blake lively's romantic
interest
on and off screen these two were an
iconic couple from 2007 to 2010 but
spent two years pretending to be in love
for fans of serena and dan
there are no regrets though the two know
their relationship made their time on
gossip girl that much better
also blake is married to ryan reynolds
now so we aren't complaining
this vampire diaries power couple dated
even before their characters did
making being a dalina shipper very
interesting
but in the middle of the series the two
sadly separated
there were rumors that ian had cheated
on nina with her friend nikki reed
ian's now wife yikes but they've since
put all those rumors to rest
nina even said the drama is in the media
it's not with us
and that she has an enormous amount of
respect and love for ian good thing we
have chemistry
okay so these two were a pretty wild
pairing on screen
being adoptive siblings and all but
off-screen the sparks were flying
michael and jennifer actually got
married and divorced while filming
dexter
but according to them there was never
any love lost they worked it out and
telling the story was never in question
because of their personal lives respect
still think you have the most awkward
breakup story we're glad that some of
these actors were able to stay
friends even after their romance ended
and kudos to those who got back into
character and did their job like nothing
ever happened
which celeb romance did you think had
the most awkward story
come chat with us below make sure to hit
that subscribe button
thanks for watching